This story happens in a movie theater. On screen, it's a Sunday afternoon, June 12, long ago. And my father is walking down the quiet streets of Brooklyn on his way to visit my mother. His clothes are newly pressed. His tie is too tight in his high collar. He jingles the coins in his pockets, thinking of the witty things he's going to say. He arrives at my mother's house. He's come too early and so is suddenly embarrassed.
这个故事发生在一间电影院里。银幕上，那是很久以前一个6月12日的周日下午。我父亲正走在布鲁克林安静的街道上，去探望我母亲。他的衣服熨得笔挺。他的领带在高领口勒得太紧了。他口袋里的硬币叮当作响，心里想着等会儿要说些俏皮话。他到了我母亲家。他来得太早了，突然感到一阵尴尬。
My aunt, my mother's sister, answers the loud bell with her napkin in her hand, for the family's still at dinner. As my father enters, my grandfather rises from the table and shakes hands with him. Finally, my mother comes downstairs, all dressed up. And my father, being engaged in conversation with my grandfather, becomes uneasy, not knowing whether to greet my mother or continue the conversation. He gets up from the chair clumsily and says hello gruffly.
我姨妈，也就是我母亲的姐妹，手里拿着餐巾，接听了响亮的门铃，因为家人还在吃晚饭。我父亲进去后，我祖父从桌旁站起来，和他握手。最后，我母亲盛装打扮下了楼。我父亲因为正忙着和我祖父交谈，变得有些局促不安，不知道该先向我母亲问好，还是继续刚才的话题。他笨拙地从椅子上站起来，粗声粗气地打了个招呼。
Well, in 1937, the same year that Django Reinhardt recorded this song, this very song, Delmore Schwartz published this story, "In Dreams Begin Responsibilities." Its originality and its beauty, its stunning beauty, was immediately and widely recognized. It was the lead story in the first issue of the influential magazine Partisan Review and we take it as the inspiration for our radio program today.
1937年，也就是简戈·莱因哈特录制这首歌的那一年，戴尔摩·舒瓦茨发表了这个故事《在梦中开始责任》。它的原创性和美感，那种令人惊叹的美，立刻得到了广泛的认可。这是影响力巨大的《党派评论》杂志创刊号的主打故事，我们也将其作为今天广播节目的灵感来源。
It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. And with Valentine's Day nearly upon us, we at This American Life , we wanted to do a show about romance. And we figured with all the writing about love and romance and dating and the rules, there are really only two romances any of us really want to hear about, really. And those are our own and our parents'. And we're sick-- we are sick of hearing about our own and talking about our own. So we thought we'd spend an hour talking about our parents.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。随着情人节临近，我们《美国生活》节目组想做一期关于浪漫的节目。我们想，在所有关于爱情、浪漫、约会和规则的文章中，其实我们真正想听的浪漫故事只有两个，那就是我们自己的和我们父母的。我们听够了谈论我们自己的那些事。所以我们想用一个小时的时间来聊聊我们的父母。
As this Delmore Schwartz story continues, it's pretty much one disturbing scene after another. The story isn't romantic in the usual way that we use the word romantic. These parents do not seem to be falling in love. They don't really seem to be in love. Instead, it's romantic in the way that great tragedy is romantic. All through the story, you can just feel the hand of fate moving in on their lives. We see their sad destiny, though they do not.
随着戴尔摩·舒瓦茨的故事继续，几乎是一个接一个令人不安的场景。这个故事并非我们通常所说的那种浪漫。这对父母似乎并没有坠入爱河。他们看起来并不像是真心相爱。相反，这是一种伟大的悲剧式的浪漫。贯穿整个故事，你可以感觉到命运之手正在介入他们的生活。我们看到了他们悲哀的宿命，而他们自己却浑然不觉。
They walk down the street. My mother is holding my father's arm and telling him of the novel which she has been reading. And my father utters judgments of the characters as the plot is made clear to him. This is a habit which he very much enjoys, for he feels the utmost superiority and confidence when he approves and condemns the behavior of other people. My mother feels satisfied by the interest which she's awakened. She's showing my father how intelligent she is and how interesting. My father tells my mother how much money he's made in the last week, exaggerating an amount which need not have been exaggerated. But my father has always felt that actualities somehow fall short. Suddenly I begin to weep.
他们走在街上。我母亲挽着我父亲的手臂，向他讲述她正在读的小说。当我父亲听懂情节后，便会对书中的人物做出评判。这是一种他非常享受的习惯，因为当他赞美或谴责他人的行为时，他会感到极大的优越感和自信。我母亲因为激起了他的兴趣而感到满足。她在向我父亲展示自己有多么聪明，多么有趣。我父亲向我母亲讲述他过去一周赚了多少钱，夸大了一个本无需夸大的数字。但我父亲一直觉得现实往往不如人意。突然，我开始哭泣。
The parents, all through this story, they're vain, they seem unfeeling, they have pretensions. They go to Coney Island, but they avoid the rides and the shows as being beneath their dignity. At one point, they decide to get their picture taken. And the photographer looks through the camera at them, and he just feels that something is wrong. And he poses them this way and that way. But nothing he tries makes it look right. Something is wrong. And finally, the father gets impatient and makes him snap the picture. When it's developed, the picture shows the father's smile turned to a grimace. And the mother's smile bright and false.
这对父母，在整个故事中，他们虚荣，似乎冷漠，而且爱装腔作势。他们去康尼岛，却因为觉得不符合他们的身份而避开了游乐设施和表演。有一次，他们决定去拍照。摄影师透过相机看着他们，觉得有些不对劲。他让他们摆出各种姿势，但怎么摆都不对。就是有些不对劲。最后，我父亲不耐烦了，催促他按下了快门。照片冲洗出来后，父亲的笑容变成了扭曲的表情，而母亲的笑容则显得灿烂而虚假。
The parents go to eat dinner at the best place on the boardwalk. There's a live band playing a waltz. The father in the story starts talking about his plans for the future, and the mother shows with an expressive face how interested she is and how impressed. The father talks more and more excitedly about his future, and the waltz is playing. And then there comes this moment. I'll read.
父母去木栈道上最好的餐馆吃晚饭。现场有一支乐队在演奏华尔兹。故事中的父亲开始谈论他对未来的计划，母亲用富有表现力的面部表情展示她有多么感兴趣和印象深刻。父亲越来越兴奋地谈论着未来，而华尔兹乐曲正在演奏。然后出现了那一刻。我来读一下。
And then as the waltz reaches the moment when all the dancers swing madly, then, then with awful daring, then he asked my mother to marry him, although awkwardly enough and puzzled, even in his excitement, at how he arrived at the proposal. And she, to make the whole business worse, begins to cry. My father looks nervously about, not knowing at all what to do now. And my mother says, "It's all I wanted from the moment I saw you," sobbing. And he finds all this very difficult, scarcely to his taste. Scarcely as he thought it would be, on his long walks over the Brooklyn Bridge, in the reverie of a fine cigar. And it was then that I stood up in the theater and shouted, "Don't do it."
当华尔兹进入所有舞者疯狂摇摆的时刻，那一刻，他怀着可怕的勇气，向我母亲求婚了，尽管那是如此笨拙，即使在兴奋中他也对自己如何得出这个求婚感到困惑。而我母亲，为了让整件事变得更糟，开始哭泣。我父亲紧张地四处张望，完全不知道现在该做什么。我母亲抽泣着说：“从见到你的那一刻起，这就是我想要的全部。”他觉得这一切非常困难，几乎不合他的胃口。几乎不像他在布鲁克林大桥上漫步、沉浸在优良雪茄的遐想中时所想象的那样。就在那时，我站在电影院里大喊：“别做！”
And then the people in the theater shush the guy. You know, shush him up. The story of our parents' romance is mesmerizing because it contains everything that we are. And when we hear it, there's a part of us that wants the lovers to get together. As we do with any romantic TV show or movie, you root for the people to fall in love. But there's another part of us that knows the consequences of that love, that knows how complicated things will get after years. And we pause.
然后电影院里的人们对他发出嘘声。你知道的，嘘他安静。关于我们父母浪漫史的故事之所以迷人，是因为它包含了我们自身的一切。当我们听到它时，内心深处有一部分希望恋人们终成眷属。就像我们看任何浪漫电视节目或电影时一样，你会支持他们相爱。但还有另一部分我们深知这种爱情的后果，知道多年以后事情会变得多么复杂。于是我们停顿了。
Well, today on our program, a variety of people tell stories about their parents' romances. Act One, a more cheerful take on this whole subject. Act Two, parents, childhood, and bats. Act Three, Julie Showalter's dad puts his hand onto her mother's lower back and leads her into the bedroom while the kids watch TV and eat popcorn. Act Four, Hilton Als' mom comes to America for his father. Act Five, can children really understand their parents' lives? Scott Carrier and his own 11-year-old daughter talk about his marriage. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，各色人等讲述了关于他们父母浪漫史的故事。第一幕，关于这个主题更轻松的视角。第二幕，父母、童年和蝙蝠。第三幕，朱莉·肖沃尔特的父亲把手放在她母亲的后腰上，领她走进卧室，而孩子们在看电视吃爆米花。第四幕，希尔顿·艾尔斯的母亲为了他的父亲来到美国。第五幕，孩子真的能理解父母的生活吗？斯科特·卡里尔和他11岁的女儿谈论他的婚姻。请继续收听。
Act One, Lighten Up. Let's change the pace a little. Shall we?
第一幕，轻松一点。让我们换个节奏，好吗？
Hello, America. I'm Brett Leveridge. I'll be reading to you today from a series of columns that I've written for Might magazine entitled "Men My Mother Dated." Let's start with Bob Petronick.
你好，美国。我是布雷特·莱弗里奇。今天我将为你朗读我为《Might》杂志撰写的一系列专栏，标题是《我母亲约会过的男人们》。让我们从鲍勃·佩特罗尼克开始。
Mom's one date with Bob Petronick in her freshman year of college was an eventful evening of firsts. He escorted her to her first fraternity party, a semi-formal affair at which she imbibed the very first beer of her young life. One beer led to another and then a third. And in short order, she was pretty tight.
妈妈大一那年与鲍勃·佩特罗尼克的唯一一次约会，是一个充满了“第一次”的难忘夜晚。他陪她参加了她的第一次兄弟会派对，那是一个半正式的场合，她在那里喝下了她年轻生命中的第一杯啤酒。一杯接一杯，很快她就喝得有点醉了。
Another female partygoer bumped into her there in the crowded ballroom, and before anything could be done, she and mom became embroiled in a hair-pulling, eye-gouging cat fight, the first such row Mom had ever been involved in. The fight was broken up by the campus police. Mom's arrest, her first, on drunk and disorderly charges led to her first night in jail. Bob, much to his credit, took up a collection around the fraternity house and posted her bail the next morning, but he never called for another date. Mom garnered 30 hours community service, six months probation, and a reputation.
派对上的另一位女性不小心撞到了她，在还没人来得及阻止之前，她和妈妈就卷入了一场揪头发、抠眼睛的猫打架，这是妈妈第一次卷入这种争吵。打架被校园警察制止了。妈妈因为酒后滋事被捕，这是她的第一次，导致了她在监狱里度过了第一晚。鲍勃，值得称赞的是，他在兄弟会募集了钱，第二天早上保释了她，但他再也没打过电话约她。妈妈因此获得了30小时的社区服务，六个月的缓刑，以及一个名声。
Vince Skankly. The summer after her junior year, Mom met a man who led her on an exciting, if frightening, adventure. His name was Vince Skankley. He was the knife thrower at a small regional circus called Blitzstein Brothers. Mom, accompanied by her friend Lois, attended each of the troop's four performances. It was after the Saturday matinee that she met Vince.
文斯·斯坎克利。大三那年的夏天，妈妈遇到一个男人，他把她带入了一段令人兴奋，却也令人恐惧的冒险。他的名字叫文斯·斯坎克利。他是布利茨斯坦兄弟马戏团的一名投刀手。妈妈在好友洛伊丝的陪同下，观看了该团的全部四场演出。就是在周六日场结束后，她遇到了文斯。
He was standing near the performers' entrance to the lone Blitzstein Brothers tent, smoking a Lucky Strike. Darkly handsome and quite a bit older than Mom, he had a worldly quality about him. He seemed cut of different cloth than any male she'd ever encountered in Okemah. They chatted a few minutes, and just before she left, he asked her to meet him following that evening's performance at the coffee shop in the town square, just a few blocks away. Mom, surprising herself, agreed.
他站在布利茨斯坦兄弟马戏团帐篷的入口处，抽着“好彩”香烟。他长得英俊且黑，比妈妈大不少，身上有一种世俗的气质。他看起来和妈妈在奥克马遇到的任何男性都不同。他们聊了几分钟，就在她离开前，他约她在那天晚上的演出结束后，去距离几条街的镇广场咖啡馆见面。妈妈令自己惊讶地答应了。
Over several cups of Joe, Vince regaled Mom with tales of the places he'd been, the things he'd seen. Blitzstein Brothers covered four states on their touring-- Oklahoma, Kansas, Arkansas, and Missouri. So Vince had been as far as Kansas City and St. Louis, towns Mom had only dreamed of seeing.
喝了几杯咖啡后，文斯向妈妈讲述了他去过的地方、见过的东西。布利茨斯坦兄弟马戏团的巡演覆盖了四个州——俄克拉荷马、堪萨斯、阿肯色和密苏里。所以文斯去过堪萨斯城和圣路易斯，那些妈妈只梦想去过的地方。
Mom was enraptured, swept away by this man. As they stepped outside the cafe, Vince revealed that his assistant, Zora, was leaving him after the next day's matinee. Taking mom in his arms and kissing her, he implored Mom to come with him on the road and be his partner. Mom agreed. They decided she would meet him the following weekend in Tulsa, where the Blitzstein Brothers were next booked. Vince met her at the bus station and took her to the room he had booked for the duration of the circus's two-week stay in Tulsa at a downtown boarding house.
妈妈被迷住了，被这个男人带走了。当他们走出咖啡馆时，文斯透露他的助手佐拉将在明天下午的场次后离开。他抱着妈妈并亲吻了她，恳求妈妈跟他一起上路，做他的搭档。妈妈同意了。他们决定下周末在塔尔萨见面，那是布利茨斯坦兄弟马戏团的下一站。文斯在汽车站接她，并带她去了他为马戏团在塔尔萨停留两周期间预订的一家市中心寄宿公寓。
He carried with him, while on the road, a fold-up cork board which he used to keep his throwing skills finely honed. And he wanted to get in a little rehearsal time with Mom before that evening's performance. As mom stood with her back to the cork, facing this man she hardly knew as he took aim with his knife, her knees began to tremble. Before she had time to protest, however, the first blade whizzed through the air towards her. It stuck in the cork firmly, just above her head. A second followed shortly thereafter, firmly embedding itself in the cork board just an inch or two away from her left shoulder.
他在路上随身携带一块可折叠的软木板，用来磨练他的投掷技巧。在那天晚上的演出前，他想让妈妈和他一起练习一下。当妈妈背对软木板站着，面对这个她几乎不认识的男人，看着他举刀瞄准时，她的膝盖开始颤抖。然而，还没等她抗议，第一把刀已经嗖地一声飞向她，稳稳地插在软木板上，就在她的头顶上方。紧接着第二把刀飞来，深深地嵌入了她左肩旁一两英寸处的软木板里。
When she felt the cold steel of the third blade at her right shoulder, she knew she had made a horrible mistake. She screamed at Vince to stop and stepped quickly away from the cork board. The cut on her shoulder was a small one, but it bled profusely. And mom was trembling. Mom never had contact with Vince again.
当她感觉到第三把刀冰冷的钢铁触碰她的右肩时，她知道自己犯了一个可怕的错误。她尖叫着让文斯停下，并迅速离开软木板。肩膀上的伤口很小，但流血不止。妈妈浑身颤抖。妈妈从此再也没和文斯有过任何接触。
Gordon Kiley. If you had asked Mom on her 21st birthday if later that year she'd become involved with a man almost three times her age, she would have laughed in your face. But that's exactly what happened. Mom had just left college, accepting a position as a secretary in Oklahoma City. She scoured the classifieds for an apartment she could afford on her tiny salary. She finally decided to take the upstairs in an older home owned by a widower, Gordon Kiley. Mr. Kiley was 59, an accountant who had lost his wife of 36 years only the year before. He had decided the house was just too quiet without her now, so he cleared out the upper floor and placed an ad. Mom was the first person to look at it.
戈登·凯利。如果你在妈妈21岁生日那天问她，今年晚些时候她是否会和一个几乎大她三倍的男人发生感情，她会嘲笑你。但这确实发生了。妈妈刚大学毕业，在俄克拉荷马城找到了一份秘书的工作。她翻遍分类广告，寻找一份她微薄工资能负担得起的公寓。她最终决定租住在一栋老房子里的楼上，房主是一位鳏夫，戈登·凯利。凯利先生59岁，是一名会计师，一年前才失去了陪伴他36年的妻子。他觉得没有妻子，房子太安静了，所以他腾出了楼上，并贴出了广告。妈妈是第一个来看房的人。
It became a habit for the two of them to spend Sunday evenings together. Mom would cook a meal, and they would often take a stroll, sometimes stopping for a movie at the Center Theatre a few short blocks away. Some evenings, they would stay in, though. Gordon would talk about his Emma, and he and Mom would listen to his Rudy Vallee 78s. Though Mom initially thought of Gordon as sort of a second father, gradually, she began to experience deeper feelings for him.
他们两人一起度过周日晚上成了习惯。妈妈会做顿饭，他们经常去散步，有时会在几条街外的中心剧院看电影。不过，有些晚上，他们会待在家里。戈登会谈论他的艾玛，他和妈妈会听他的鲁迪·瓦利78转唱片。虽然妈妈起初把戈登看作是第二个父亲，但逐渐地，她开始对他产生了更深的情感。
One Sunday night as Rudy Vallee sang, they danced a foxtrot. Without speaking a word, Gordon, ever so gently, kissed Mom's lips. She returned the kiss but instantly regretted it, feeling something just wasn't right. She feigned a headache and excused herself, retreating to the bedroom upstairs.
一个周日晚上，当鲁迪·瓦利唱歌时，他们跳起了狐步舞。戈登一言不发，极其温柔地亲吻了妈妈的嘴唇。她回吻了，但立刻感到后悔，觉得有什么不对劲。她谎称头痛，告罪上楼回了卧室。
The next morning, both Gordon and Mom tried to behave as if nothing had happened, but the tension between them was palpable. They continued this way for 10 or 12 days, at which point Mom told Gordon she felt she must find another place to live. Within a week, she had moved out, and two months later, Gordon sold the home he had shared with Emma and moved to Cedar Rapids, Iowa, where his son and daughter-in-law lived. Mom never spoke to Gordon again.
第二天早上，戈登和妈妈都试图表现得好像什么都没发生过，但他们之间的紧张气氛显而易见。他们就这样持续了10到12天，在那之后，妈妈告诉戈登她觉得必须找个地方住。一周内，她搬走了，两个月后，戈登卖掉了他和艾玛共同居住的房子，搬到了爱荷华州的锡达拉皮兹，他儿子和儿媳住那里。妈妈再也没有和戈登说过话。
Brett Leveridge's column, "Men My Mother Dated," appears in Might magazine.
布雷特·莱弗里奇的专栏《我母亲约会过的男人们》刊登在《Might》杂志上。
Brett, does the woman in these stories seem like the same woman you think of as your mom?
布雷特，这些故事里的那个女人，和你心目中作为母亲的那个女人是同一个人吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I mean it's sort of a larger-than-life version of her, a sort of a mythological version of my mom.
是的。我是说，那是一个某种程度上超乎寻常的她，一个我母亲的神话般的版本。
Was your mom very popular?
你母亲很受欢迎吗？
Yeah. She went to see The Eddie Cantor Story six times with six different men. My father does not know which he was, and that just tells you right there that this is someone that a lot of men were asking out. Now, why in the world she didn't along about number three or four, say, "You know, I've seen that. Could we see something else?"
是的。她和六个不同的男人看了六次《艾迪·坎特传》。我父亲不知道他是哪一个，这足以说明当时有很多男人在约她。那么，为什么她在第三或第四个时，没有说：“你知道，我看过那部片子了。我们能看点别的吗？”
And with each one, she pretended she hadn't seen it?
她和每一个人都假装没看过？
She pretended she hadn't seen it with each one of them, yeah.
是的，她和他们每个人都假装没看过。
Wow.
哇。
I don't know if that was sort of a little sign of the era that she was living in and that a more assertive '90s woman might say, "Sorry numbers four, five, six, and seven, I've seen that."
我不知道这是否是她所处时代的某种迹象，如果是90年代更自信的女性，可能会说：“抱歉，第四、第五、第六和第七位先生，我看过那部电影了。”
What does your mom have to say about The Eddie Cantor Story?
你母亲对《艾迪·坎特传》怎么看？
She probably tried to put it out of her mind as much as possible. But I'm guessing she could recite dialogue from it, even now.
她可能尽量把它抛之脑后。但我猜即使到现在，她也能背诵里面的台词。
I bet there's pretty much anything we want to know about Eddie Cantor, she's ready to answer.
我敢说关于艾迪·坎特，任何我们想知道的事情，她都随时准备回答。
Or at least the Hollywood version of it. She could probably recite lines from it, I'm guessing.
或者至少是好莱坞版本的事情。我猜她大概能背诵里面的台词。
What do you think the fascination is with this kind of story?
你认为这种故事有什么迷人之处？
I think that most of us have an interest in our parents' lives before they were our parents. It's sort of hard to imagine them where we are, in our 20s or 30s or teens, dating and struggling with all that and deciding what to do with our lives. And so any stories that reveal the classic "Mom" at an earlier stage in her life, when she was going through some of the travails that we all face, I think are sort of attractive.
我认为我们大多数人对父母成为我们父母之前的生平感兴趣。很难想象他们在我们现在的年龄，二十多岁、三十多岁或十几岁时，约会、挣扎并决定自己生活该怎么走的样子。所以任何揭示那个经典的“妈妈”在早年阶段的故事，当她经历着我们每个人都要面对的磨难时，我认为都是很有吸引力的。
See, I wonder if part of it is people need an origin myth, especially secular people. You need a myth of "Where did I come from?" to explain who you are.
我想知道这是否有一部分原因是人们需要一个起源神话，尤其是世俗的人。你需要一个“我从哪里来”的神话来解释你是谁。
True enough. I think that's probably very true. It's a little glimpse into the world before "me."
很有道理。我想这大概是非常正确的。这是对“我”之前的世界的一瞥。
More stories of Brett Leveridge's mom as our program continues.
随着节目的继续，会有更多关于布雷特·莱弗里奇母亲的故事。
Act Two, Mom, Dad, Bats. Well, if in fact the story of our parents' romance is part creation myth, we offer this story from Bia Lowe.
第二幕，妈妈、爸爸、蝙蝠。嗯，如果说父母浪漫史的故事确实是起源神话的一部分，我们来看看比亚·洛的这个故事。
It's 1962, and I will soon be 12 years old. Thus far, I have lived in fear of little but vampires. My father drinks, my parents fight, the bleak house trembles, but I fear only Dracula. In these olden days, the story of Dracula is a bedtime waking nightmare, a drama in which I stockade myself against the dark powers of annihilation. All children are fundamentalists, and every cell in my body is zealous to win the fight against the night, my small ego trying to sustain itself against the forces I cannot name.
那是1962年，我很快就要满12岁了。到目前为止，我除了害怕吸血鬼，几乎什么都不怕。我父亲酗酒，我父母打架，这个阴沉的房子在颤抖，但我只怕德古拉。在那些旧时光里，德古拉的故事是一个睡前醒来的噩梦，是一个我为了抵御黑暗毁灭力量而把自己围困起来的戏剧。所有孩子都是原教旨主义者，我身体里的每一个细胞都热衷于赢得这场与夜晚的战斗，我那小小的自我在努力维持，对抗着我无法命名的力量。
In 1962, my parents travel through the Mediterranean. They are in their mid-40s, and looking back on it, I'm sure they were trying to rekindle the romance in their troubled marriage. Under the lax supervision of my grandmother, I spent hours alone in the woods. One day, I explore an old chicken shack, a derelict chicken coop. The timbers are weathered to a pewter, and lichen, as finely laced as antimacassars, have grafted themselves to the siding.
1962年，我父母去地中海旅行。他们那时四十出头，如今回想起来，我肯定他们是在试图挽救他们那段充满麻烦的婚姻。在祖母疏于监管的情况下，我在树林里独自待了几个小时。有一天，我探索一个旧鸡棚，一个废弃的鸡舍。木材风化成铅灰色，像蕾丝一样精美的地衣附着在护墙板上。
At first, there is little inside to sustain my intrigue, some ancient straw and a few daddy longlegs. Then I notice something furry in a crack near the door jamb. I poke it with my finger, but nothing happens. I poke again. This time, a small claw strikes back, calling my bluff. It feels silly to be reprimanded by such a small creature, but I don't push my luck. Though I've never seen one before, there's no mistaking it's a bat. The little foot shredding the air between us has permanently marred the membrane between the real and the make-believe. From that day forward, I try to strike a compromise between the tiny creature in the door jamb and the emblem of my dread.
起初，里面没什么能引起我兴趣的，只有一些古老的稻草和几只幽灵蛛。然后，我注意到门框附近的一条缝里有什么毛茸茸的东西。我用手指戳了戳，没有反应。我又戳了一下。这一次，一只小爪子反击过来，揭穿了我的虚张声势。被这样一个小生物斥责感到很愚蠢，但我不想冒险。虽然我从没见过这种生物，但毫无疑问这是一只蝙蝠。那只在我俩之间划破空气的小脚，永远破坏了现实与想象之间的那层薄膜。从那天起，我试图在门缝里的这个小生物和我恐惧的象征之间达成妥协。
Bats were sprinters on the evolutionary track, and while our forebearers were still small as lemurs, still clinging to branches, their ancestors looked remarkably like themselves. Our limbs took painstaking millennia to grow beyond a childhood of rodentia, while their fingers already extended, Nosferatu-like, to support the open umbrella of their wings. No wonder we fear them. In the presence of bats, we sense the occurrence of time before us. In their impossible faces, we see a life that eludes us, centuries of caves, forests of unfamiliar trees, Edens buried under rubble. We are like Nabakov's friend who, upon seeing a home movie taken before his birth, realized to his horror he did not exist there at all and that nobody mourned his absence.
蝙蝠是进化赛道上的短跑运动员，而当我们的祖先还像狐猴那么小、只能抓着树枝时，它们的祖先看起来就和它们现在差不多。我们的肢体经历了痛苦的几百万年才长出啮齿类动物的童年，而它们的手指却早已伸展，如同诺斯费拉图一般，支撑起它们翅膀那把张开的伞。难怪我们害怕它们。在蝙蝠的存在中，我们感受到了我们之前的时光。在它们不可能的面孔里，我们看到了一个逃避我们的生命，数百年的洞穴，森林中不熟悉的树木，埋在瓦砾下的伊甸园。我们就像纳博科夫的朋友，他在看到出生前拍摄的家庭电影时，惊恐地意识到自己根本不存在于那里，而且没有人为他的缺席而哀悼。
One morning in 1962 after my parents have returned from their trip, I enter their bedroom to have my mother sign my blue books. She's disappeared from her half of the bed, but my father, propped on his elbow, volunteers his signature. I reach across the bed and offer up my exams, which are the color of robins' eggs. As he autographs them, and I smell the spice of his skin, I notice my mother's form concealed under the covers behind him. Later that day, I'm sent home from school with my first menstrual cramps. I lay in bed and savor my morning's discovery, the only time I ever suspected my parents of having sex.
1962年的一天早上，我父母旅行归来后，我走进他们的卧室让母亲在我的练习册上签字。她不在床的那一边，但我父亲用肘部支撑着身体，主动要为我签名。我伸手越过床，递上我那些知更鸟蛋颜色的考试卷。当他签名时，我闻到了他皮肤上的香料味，我注意到母亲的身影藏在他身后的被子里。那天晚些时候，我因为第一次经痛被从学校送回家。我躺在床上，回味着早上的发现，那是我唯一一次怀疑父母在进行性行为。
Recently, I was sitting with my mother in the house she has shared for 20 years with a new husband I've come to think of as a father. We rest our feet among piles of magazines on a small wooden coffee table. It's the oldest thing in this house that bears the stamp of my history. I remember the sour taste of its varnish, how my four-year-old tongue once traced the carved bodies that ran on all sides. I'd always thought they were the bodies of flying men or dogs in capes.
最近，我正和我母亲坐在她与一位新丈夫共度20年的房子里，我已经把那个人视为父亲。我们把脚放在一张小木咖啡桌上的杂志堆中。这是这栋房子里带有我历史烙印的最古老的东西。我记得它那酸涩的清漆味道，记得我四岁时的舌头曾如何沿着四周雕刻的身体划过。我一直以为那是飞行的人或披着斗篷的狗的身体。
"Are those bats?" I ask her.
“那是蝙蝠吗？”我问她。
"Yes. It's the first piece of furniture your father and I ever bought. We were living in a little flat in Chinatown. The Chinese believe bats bring happiness." I imagine my parents then, smooth-skinned, thinner, little to live on but love. Their room is furnished with the donations of well-wishing relatives, a hooked rug, mismatched chairs, a creaky four-poster. I can't help thinking my mother likes being on top. But in those young days, their sex is playful, their smell mingling with the smoke and ginger of the street.
“是的。这是你父亲和我买的第一件家具。我们当时住在唐人街的一间小公寓里。中国人认为蝙蝠会带来幸福。”我想象着当时的父母，皮肤光滑，身材瘦削，几乎没有生活来源，只有爱情。他们的房间布置着好心亲戚捐赠的物品，一张钩针编织的地毯，不成对的椅子，一张嘎吱作响的四柱床。我不由得想到母亲喜欢在上面。但在那些年轻的日子里，他们的性生活是俏皮的，他们的气味与街道上的烟味和姜味混合在一起。
Near the bed, at the center of their new lives, is the table bought for hope and a toss at the future. The bats draw back the seam of night like coverlets for my parents to fall into and sew that seam back up at dawn, like the last good-luck kiss before rising for work. These lovers are strangers to me, un-parents, animals not yet flexing around the beginning of my life. Their cells mingle hundreds of times before a fluke will yank me from the void.
在那张承载着希望和对未来憧憬的桌子旁边，就在他们新生活的中心，蝙蝠像床罩一样拉开夜晚的缝隙，让我的父母陷入其中，并在黎明时分缝合那道缝隙，就像起床上班前的最后一个好运之吻。这些恋人对我来说是陌生人，是非父母，是还没有在我生命开始时弯曲的动物。他们的细胞混合了数百次，直到一个偶然的因素把我从虚空中拽出来。
An excerpt from Bia Low's essay, "Bats," which appears in her book Wild Ride. She's working on another book of essays.
比亚·洛的散文《蝙蝠》的节选，出自她的书《疯狂的旅程》。她正在撰写另一本散文集。
Act Three, It's Not the Heat.
第三幕，不是因为炎热。
For a long time, when asked if my parents loved each other, I would arch my eyebrow and say, "Love? Well, I guess by their standards," thereby implying that I knew more about love, neurotic dependency, and the difference between the two, than they ever did.
很长一段时间里，当被问及父母是否相爱时，我会挑起眉毛说：“爱？嗯，我想按照他们的标准吧，”以此暗示我比他们更了解爱、神经质的依赖以及两者之间的区别。
Julie Showalter's parents were married in 1944, high school sweethearts from Dimmitt, Texas. When her father died 41 years later, they were still married. In between, they had three daughters and divorced each other twice. This is our program, of course, about our parents' romances, and Julie remembers hers this way.
朱莉·肖沃尔特的父母于1944年结婚，是德克萨斯州迪米特的的高中恋人。她父亲41年后去世时，他们依然保持着婚姻关系。在这期间，他们有三个女儿，离婚了两次。当然，这是我们关于父母浪漫史的节目，朱莉是这样记得她父母的。
Because she was beautiful, he wanted her to be glamorous. When we were the poorest we ever were, living on a turkey farm in a four-room house with linoleum floors, he bought her a silver tea and coffee service for Christmas. We'd just gotten television then, and I think he saw her as Bess Myerson, floating in mink on The Big Payoff or Arlene Francis pouring coffee for her guests on The Home Show . Another year, he did buy her mink, a cape from Sears. She exchanged it for a gas range.
因为她很美，他希望她富有魅力。当我们最贫穷的时候，住在火鸡农场的一间四室房子里，地板上铺着油毡，他圣诞节给她买了一套银茶具和咖啡具。我们那时才刚有电视，我想他把她看作是贝丝·迈尔森，漂浮在《The Big Payoff》节目里的水貂皮大衣中，或者是阿琳·弗朗西斯在《The Home Show》节目里为她的客人倒咖啡。又一年，他确实给她买了水貂皮大衣，一件西尔斯百货买的披肩。她把它换成了一个煤气灶。
They were hot, an embarrassment to growing daughters. She'd put her hand flat against his cheek after he had shaved and just hold it there while he moved his lips against her thumb. When guiding her into a room, he put his hand on the small of her back, and you could see his fingers flex, see him feeling her back under the dress, see her responding. Sometimes in the evening, they'd have a drink, put on an old record, and dance to Glenn Miller. My sisters and I would watch them, handsome, graceful, sex-charged. Then they'd go to bed early, leaving us trying to concentrate on TV and popcorn.
他们很火辣，这对成长中的女儿来说是个尴尬。在他刮完胡子后，她会把手平放在他的脸颊上，就这样握着，而他则用嘴唇摩擦她的拇指。在指引她进入房间时，他把手放在她后腰上，你可以看到他的手指在弯曲，看到他在感受裙子下她的背部，看到她的回应。有时在晚上，他们会喝一杯，放一张旧唱片，随着格伦·米勒的音乐跳舞。我和我的姐妹们会看着他们，英俊、优雅、充满性魅力。然后他们会早早上床睡觉，留下我们试图专注于电视和爆米花。
When I was 11, I saw her reach up from where she was sitting and zip his trousers. Then she patted him just below the belt. This is marriage, I thought. This is sex. This is knowing another body. Drinking was his weakness, and sometimes when he was drinking, there'd be a woman. "A certain kind of woman finds your father very attractive," Mother told us.
我11岁那年，我看到她从坐着的地方伸手去拉他的裤子拉链。然后她拍了拍他腰带下方。我想，这就是婚姻。这就是性。这就是了解另一个身体。喝酒是他的弱点，有时当他喝酒时，会有别的女人。“某种女人觉得你父亲很有吸引力，”母亲告诉我们。
Their second divorce may have been the shortest in Missouri history. The day after it was final, a week after she'd sent her diamond rings out to be reset-- rings, by the way, that she was still paying off, another one of his flamboyant gifts-- the next day, she took him back. Literally took him. I was 19, the oldest, so she made me drive. "We're going to get your father," she said.
他们的第二次离婚可能是密苏里历史上最短的。离婚最终确定后的第二天，在她把钻戒送去重新镶嵌的一周后——顺便说一下，戒指她还在付钱，这是他那挥霍无度的礼物之一——第二天，她把他接了回来。确实是接了回来。我当时19岁，是最大的，所以她让我开车。“我们要去接你父亲，”她说。
We knew where he was. He was with Lorna, one of those women. When we pulled up, Mother shook her head at the degradation. Lorna's house had no grass in the yard, just hard-packed dirt. And old wringer washer that someone had tried to make into a platter sat on the sagging front porch. Mother sent me ahead. "Make sure he's in there."
我们知道他在哪里。他和洛娜在一起，那是那种女人之一。当我们开到时，母亲对他那种堕落摇了摇头。洛娜的院子里没有草，只有坚硬的泥土。门廊上放着一台别人试图改成盘子的旧绞干洗衣机。母亲让我先走过去。“确保他在里面。”
Through the screen door, I could see half a dozen men playing cards. My eyes adjusted enough to pick out Daddy. He looked loose, happy, drinking, but not drunk. Lorna came in from the kitchen carrying a bowl of potato chips. "Julie," she said, "come on in. Look Bill," she turned to Daddy, "Julie's come to see us."
透过纱门，我可以看到半打男人在玩牌。我的眼睛调整了一下，认出了爸爸。他看起来很放松、快乐、喝酒，但没喝醉。洛娜从厨房走出来，端着一碗薯片。“朱莉，”她说，“进来吧。看，比尔，”她转向爸爸，“朱莉来看我们了。”
He started to get up, but his attention was drawn to the front porch. Mother stood in the open screen door with the sunlight behind her. She was wearing a white summer dress, cut straight and close to her body, and high heels that showed her long, slim calves. The sun made her red hair seem almost to vibrate. She looked cool, beautiful, elegant, like Suzy Parker, the model in the ads for Revlon's Fire & Ice. All the men in the room stared at her without talking.
他开始站起来，但他的注意力被前门廊吸引了。母亲站在敞开的纱门里，阳光在她身后。她穿着一件白色夏装，裁剪得贴身，高跟鞋衬托出她纤细的小腿。阳光让她的红发似乎在颤动。她看起来很酷、美丽、优雅，就像露华浓“火与冰”广告里的模特苏西·帕克。屋里所有的男人都目不转睛地看着她，一言不发。
I looked from her to Lorna, a blousy woman with ink-black hair and mascara smeared under her eyes. Mother walked over and put her hand on Daddy's shoulder. "Come on, sweetie," she said. "We're taking you home."
我从她看向洛娜，一个有着墨黑色头发、睫毛膏糊在眼睛下方的臃肿女人。母亲走过去，把手放在爸爸的肩膀上。“走吧，亲爱的，”她说，“我们接你回家。”
Julie Showalter. Her parents' remarriage lasted until her father died 18 years after this. Much of this story is told in Julie's novel, Needlework, which is looking for a publisher.
朱莉·肖沃尔特。她父母的再婚持续到她父亲在这件事18年后去世。这个故事的大部分内容在朱莉的小说《针线活》中讲述，该书正在寻找出版商。
[MUSIC - "I'VE GOT A CRUSH ON YOU" BY JENNY MAGNUS]
[音乐——珍妮·马格努斯的《I'VE GOT A CRUSH ON YOU》]
Jenny Magnus. Her first solo album comes out this May on Eighth Day Records. Coming up, reporter Scott Carrier's 11-year-old daughter explains his marriage. And Hilton Als' in a minute when our program continues.
珍妮·马格努斯。她的第一张个人专辑将于今年五月在第八天唱片公司发行。接下来，记者斯科特·卡里尔的11岁女儿将解释他的婚姻。希尔顿·艾尔斯也将在我们节目继续进行时出现。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme on our program and invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, as Valentine's Day approaches, our parents' romances.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，并邀请各路作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，随着情人节临近，主题是我们父母的浪漫史。
Hello America. It's time again for another episode of "Men My Mother Dated." Here's the man with the mom, Brett Leveridge.
你好，美国。又到了《我母亲约会过的男人们》的新一集时间了。这位是带着妈妈故事的人，布雷特·莱弗里奇。
Bob Wills. My parents hadn't been together very long when they were invited to join their friends Don and Dorothy for an evening at the Trianon Ballroom in downtown Oklahoma City. Bob Wills and his Texas Playboys were the headliners on that evening's bill, and their special brand of Western swing kept the dance floor packed the whole night long. From Mom's initial turn around the dance floor, Wills couldn't take his eyes off of her. He'd tipped his huge Stetson hat every time she turkey trotted by, and winked whenever he managed to catch her eye.
鲍勃·威尔斯。我父母在一起没多久，就被邀请和他们的朋友唐和多萝西一起去俄克拉荷马城市中心的特里亚农舞厅度过一晚。鲍勃·威尔斯和他的德州花花公子乐队是那天晚上的头牌，他们独特的西部摇摆乐让舞池整晚都挤满了人。从妈妈第一次在舞池转圈开始，威尔斯就目不转睛地盯着她。每次她随着音乐小跑经过，他都会掀起那顶巨大的牛仔帽，每当他能捕捉到她的目光时，他都会眨眼示意。
Mom, a young woman at the peak of her beauty, certainly had no desire to encourage Wills, who was well into his 50s. But Don and my father, having a good time at Mom's expense, kept swinging her right up stage-side, and turning Mom so that she was forced to face the winking Wills. Mom, finally fed up, refused for a while to dance. But when, after a bit, she heard the orchestra strike up the opening strains of "Faded Love," her favorite Bob Wills tune, she gave in and accompanied my father to the dance floor.
妈妈，正处于美貌巅峰的年轻女性，当然没有兴趣鼓励威尔斯，因为他已经五十多岁了。但是唐和我父亲，以妈妈为乐，一直把她摇到舞台边，让妈妈不得不面对那个眨眼的威尔斯。妈妈终于受够了，有一阵子拒绝跳舞。但当过了一会儿，她听到乐队奏响了她最爱的鲍勃·威尔斯乐曲《褪色的爱》的开场乐时，她屈服了，陪着我父亲走进了舞池。
Soon, Dad felt a tap, tap, tap upon his shoulder, signifying that someone was seeking to cut in to take a turn around the floor with Mom. By now, you must surely have guessed that it was Wills. Dad stepped aside, and Mom found herself firmly in Wills' clutches. Mom felt there was little she could do but to grit her teeth and behave in gracious fashion until song's end. But as the orchestra, missing nary a beat, segued right into "San Antonio Rose," Mom felt, as he pulled her into an even tighter embrace, Wills' right hand slowly but steadily creeping downward along her spine until it came to rest upon her left-- well, let us say, her left hip.
很快，爸爸感到肩膀被拍了拍，意思是有人想插队，带妈妈在舞池转一圈。现在，你肯定猜到了那是威尔斯。爸爸退到一边，妈妈发现自己被威尔斯牢牢地抓住了。妈妈觉得除了咬牙切齿地优雅表现到乐曲结束外，别无他法。但当乐队节奏丝毫不乱地转入《圣安东尼奥玫瑰》时，妈妈感到，随着他将她拉入更紧的怀抱，威尔斯的右手缓慢而稳定地沿着她的脊柱向下，直到停在她的左——嗯，让我们说，她的左臀上。
Uttering not a word, Mom fixed upon Wills an angry glare of an intensity that few have experienced, and fewer still have survived. Having wilted under the heat of this glare a number of times myself, believe me when I say, gentle listener, it can make a strong man weep. Wills was not up to the challenge. He quickly removed his hand, cleared his throat, tipped his hat, said, "Excuse me, ma'am," and hurriedly made his way back to the stage, whereupon he immediately called out for "Take Me Back to Tulsa" in double time.
妈妈一言不发，用一种很少有人经历过、更少人能幸存的愤怒目光盯着威尔斯。我自己已经在这种目光的炙热下退缩过很多次了，相信我，亲爱的听众，它能让一个硬汉流泪。威尔斯承受不了这种挑战。他迅速拿开手，清了清嗓子，摘下帽子，说了句“抱歉，女士”，然后匆忙回到舞台，随即便立即要求以双倍速度演奏《带我回塔尔萨》。
Throughout the remainder of the evening, whenever Mom came within 10 yards of the stage, Wills managed somehow to look busy, sorting through the musical charts on the bandstand, attending to an out-of-tune string on his fiddle, conducting the orchestra on a number they had played hundreds of times. During the next intermission, the waitress brought a round of beers to Mom and Dad's table and explained that they came compliments of the King of Western Swing himself, Bob Wills.
在那晚剩下的时间里，每当妈妈走到距离舞台10码以内的地方，威尔斯都能设法让自己看起来很忙，翻弄着乐谱，处理小提琴上的一根走调弦，指挥着他们已经演奏过数百次的乐曲。在接下来的幕间休息时，服务员给妈妈和爸爸的桌子送来了一轮啤酒，并解释说这是西部摇摆之王鲍勃·威尔斯本人请客的。
Terry Plimpton. Terry has remained a real mystery to Mom. They dated for five months during her sophomore year of college, even talked a bit of a future together. Terry was, in many ways, Mom's dream man. A perfect gentleman, a terrific dancer with a wonderful voice, a gourmet cook. Their shared interests were many. They liked the same movies, the same music, though he was a bigger Judy Garland fan than she. Without warning, though, he left school and took off for San Francisco, where he remains to this day. Terry never married.
特里·普林普顿。特里对妈妈来说一直是个谜。他们在她大二时约会了五个月，甚至讨论过在一起的未来。特里在很多方面都是妈妈的梦中情人。一位完美的绅士，一位出色的舞者，声音美妙，还是位美食厨师。他们的共同爱好很多。他们喜欢相同的电影，相同的音乐，尽管他是比她更狂热的朱迪·加兰粉丝。然而，毫无预兆地，他退学并动身去了旧金山，至今仍在那里。特里从未结婚。
Kathy Simpkins. This would-be suitor was not a man, and Mom never really dated her. Still, the story will be told. After her sophomore year of college, Mom decided to take a very difficult course load in summer school. She knew that she would have to be terribly focused to pull this off, so she swore off dating for the duration. Not that it was easy. The phone rang often, but Mom spoke with these gentlemen callers just long enough so as not the seem uncivil. The answer was always the same. "I'm sorry, I'm concentrating on my studies this summer, and I'm not interested in going out. Thanks for calling."
凯西·辛普金斯。这位准追求者不是男性，妈妈也从没真正和她约会过。尽管如此，故事还是要讲的。大二暑假后，妈妈决定在暑期班修一门非常困难的课程。她知道自己必须极其专注才能完成，所以她发誓在那个暑假期间拒绝约会。并不是这很容易。电话经常响，但妈妈和这些男来电者谈话的时间仅够显得有礼貌。答案总是相同的：“抱歉，我今年夏天专注于学业，没兴趣出门。谢谢来电。”
Mom's roommate for the summer was an older woman of 25, Kathy Simpkins. Kathy had just begun her studies as a physical education major that spring, after serving a stint in the Air Force. Mom and Kathy got along fine. They often cooked dinner together on those summer evenings, but they were not particularly close. In fact, Kathy knew nothing of Mom's romantic or sexual proclivities. All she knew was that every man who called for Mom was firmly, if politely, rebuffed. So it's not so hard to understand how Kathy might have reached some misbegotten conclusions regarding Mom's orientation.
妈妈那个夏天的室友是一位25岁的年长女性，凯西·辛普金斯。凯西在服完兵役后，于那年春天刚开始作为体育专业学生学习。妈妈和凯西相处得很好。她们经常在夏天的晚上一起做晚饭，但并不特别亲近。事实上，凯西对妈妈的浪漫或性倾向一无所知。她只知道每个打电话找妈妈的男人都被礼貌而坚定地拒绝了。所以不难理解凯西是如何对妈妈的取向得出一些错误结论的。
It all came to a head after one of those home-cooked meals. Mom and Kathy had gone shopping together that afternoon and splurged on a leg of lamb and a bottle of Beaujolais. Once the food was finished and the plates placed in the kitchen sink, Kathy, emboldened by her third glass of wine, sat right beside Mom on what was rather a large and roomy davenport and, much to Mom's surprise, transformed into an octipus di amore.
这一切在一次家常便饭后达到了顶点。妈妈和凯西那天下午一起去购物，奢侈地买了一只羊腿和一瓶博若莱酒。饭吃完了，盘子放进厨房水槽后，凯西在第三杯酒的壮胆下，坐在了妈妈身边那张相当大而宽敞的沙发上，出乎妈妈意料地，变成了一只“爱之章鱼”。
Mom, caught more than a little off-guard, extracted herself from Kathy's clutches, excused herself, and hurriedly sped off to her bedroom, quickly locking the door behind her. Things were a little awkward for a day or two afterwards. Only a few words were exchanged between the two, but eventually they sat down and talked things over. Mom explained that her moratorium on men was a temporary one, and Kathy apologized for her aggressive behavior. The rest of the summer went by without incident.
妈妈被搞得有点措手不及，从凯西的怀抱中挣脱出来，告罪一声，匆忙奔向卧室，并在身后迅速锁上了门。之后的一两天里，气氛有点尴尬。两人之间没说几句话，但最终她们坐下来谈了谈。妈妈解释说她对男人的禁令只是暂时的，凯西为自己的激进行为道歉了。那个夏天的其余时间平安无事。
Today, Kathy resides in Grand Rapids, Michigan, where she enjoyed a long career as a physical education instructor. She retired only last year. She and Mom still exchange Christmas cards.
今天，凯西住在密歇根州的大急流城，在那里她作为体育教练享受了长期的职业生涯。她去年才退休。她和妈妈至今还交换圣诞贺卡。
Brett Leveridge's column, "Men My Mother Dated," is in Might magazine and on the net at www.brettnews-- that's B-R-E-T-T-N-E-W-S-- .com.
布雷特·莱弗里奇的专栏《我母亲约会过的男人们》刊登在《Might》杂志和网上，网址是www.brettnews--也就是B-R-E-T-T-N-E-W-S-- .com。
Act Four. Hilton Als' mother called herself a Negress. In Als' book, The Women , he writes about how she used the word. He says the word usually conjures certain stereotypes-- single mother, public aid, low-paying jobs, like his mother. The stoic mom, selfless to a fault, who takes life as it comes, like his mother.
第四幕。希尔顿·艾尔斯的母亲称自己为“Negress”（黑人女性）。在艾尔斯的书《女人》中，他写到了她是如何使用这个词的。他说这个词通常会让人联想到某些刻板印象——单身母亲、公共救济、低薪工作，就像他母亲一样。坚忍的母亲，甚至到了无私的地步，随遇而安，就像他母亲一样。
But he says in reality his mother was really not much like these stereotypes. That's part of his story. Another part is about her long illness. He says that she was sick for years, sick in a way that got a lot of attention from everyone around her. She lost a leg to diabetes, lost a kidney, lost vision in one eye. Here's how his memoir begins.
但他说实际上，他的母亲并不像这些刻板印象。这是他故事的一部分。另一部分是关于她长期的疾病。他说她病了很多年，病的方式引起了她周围所有人的注意。她因为糖尿病截去了一条腿，失去了一个肾脏，一只眼睛失明了。这是他回忆录的开头。
Until the end, my mother never discussed her way of being. She avoided explaining the impetus behind her emigration from Barbados to Manhattan. She avoided explaining that she had not been motivated by the same desire for personal gain and opportunity that drove most female immigrants. She avoided recounting the fact that she had immigrated to America to follow the man who eventually became my father and whom she had known in his previous incarnation as her first and only husband's closest friend. She avoided explaining how she had left her husband, by whom she had two daughters, after he returned to Barbados from England and the Second World War addicted to morphine. She was silent about the fact that, having been married once, she refused to marry again.
直到最后，我母亲从未讨论过她的生活方式。她避免解释从巴巴多斯移民到曼哈顿背后的动机。她避免解释她并没有受到大多数女性移民所追求的个人利益和机会的驱使。她避免讲述她移民到美国是为了追随后来成为我父亲的那个男人，那个她在先前的生活中作为她第一任也是唯一一任丈夫的最亲密朋友所认识的人。她避免解释她是如何离开她的丈夫的——她与他有两个女儿——在他在第二次世界大战后从英国回到巴巴多斯并染上吗啡瘾之后。对于自己曾经结婚却拒绝再婚的事实，她保持沉默。
She avoided explaining that my father, who had grown up relatively rich in Barbados, and whom she had known as a child, remained a child, and emigrated to America with his mother and his two sisters, women whose home he never left. She never mentioned that she had been attracted to my father's beauty and wealth partially because those were two things she would never know. She never discussed how she had visited my father in his room at night and afterward, crept down the stairs stealthily to return to her own home and her six children, four of them produced by her union with my father, who remained a child.
她避免解释我父亲，他在巴巴多斯相对富裕长大，她从小就认识他，却一直像个孩子，带着他的母亲和两个姐妹移民到美国，他从未离开过她们的家。她从未提过她被父亲的美貌和财富所吸引，部分原因是因为那是她永远不会知道的两件事。她从未讨论过她是如何在深夜造访父亲的房间，事后又偷偷溜下楼梯，回到她自己的家，回到她的六个孩子身边，其中四个是他与依然像个孩子的父亲结合而生。
She avoided explaining that my father, like most children and like most men, resented his children, four girls, two boys, for not growing up quickly enough so that they would leave home and take his responsibility away with them. She avoided recounting how my father, because he was a child, tried to distance himself from his children and his resentment of them through his derisive humor, teasing them to the point of cruelty.
她避免解释我父亲，像大多数孩子和大多数男人一样，痛恨他的孩子——四个女孩，两个男孩——因为他们没有长大得足够快，这样他们就不会离开家，带走他的责任。她避免讲述我父亲如何因为是个孩子，试图通过冷嘲热讽来疏远他的孩子和对他们的怨恨，戏弄他们到残酷的地步。
She also avoided recounting how her children, in order to shield themselves against the spittle of his derisive humor, absented themselves in his presence and eventually in the presence of any form of entertainment deliberately aimed at provoking laughter. She avoided explaining that in response to this resentment, my father also vaunted his beauty and wealth over his children as qualities they would never share. She was silent about the mysterious bond she and my father shared, a bond so deep and volatile that their children felt forever diminished by their love and forever compelled to disrupt, disapprove, avoid, or try to become a part of the love shared between any couple, specifically men and women.
她还避免讲述她的孩子们为了保护自己免受他尖刻嘲讽的唾沫，在他面前表现出不在场，并最终在任何旨在引发笑声的娱乐形式面前也表现出不在场。她避免解释为了回应这种怨恨，我父亲还向孩子们夸耀他的美貌和财富，认为这些是他们永远无法分享的品质。她对她和父亲共同拥有的神秘纽带保持沉默，这种纽带如此深沉而易变，以至于他们的孩子感到被他们的爱情永远地削弱了，并永远被迫去破坏、不赞成、回避或试图成为任何情侣（特别是男女）之间分享的爱情的一部分。
She avoided mentioning the fact that my father had other women, other families, in cities such as Miami and Boston, cities my father roamed, like a bewildered child. She was silent about the fact that my father's mother and sisters told her about the other women and children my father had, probably as a test to see how much my mother could stand to hear about my father, whom his mother and sisters felt only they could understand and love, which is one reason my father remained a child. She avoided explaining that she created a position of power for herself in this common world by being a mother to children and childlike men as she attempted to separate from her parents and siblings by being nice, an attitude they could never understand since they weren't.
她避免提到我父亲在迈阿密和波士顿等城市还有其他女人、其他家庭的事实，那些我父亲像个困惑的孩子一样漫游的城市。她对于父亲的母亲和姐妹们告诉她有关父亲还有其他女人和孩子的事保持沉默，这可能是为了测试我母亲能忍受听到多少关于我父亲的事，他的母亲和姐妹们觉得只有她们才能理解和爱他，这也是我父亲依然像个孩子的一个原因。她避免解释她通过作为孩子和孩子气的男人的母亲，在那个共同的世界中为自己创造了一个权力地位，因为她试图通过表现得善良来与她的父母和兄弟姐妹分离，这种态度他们永远无法理解，因为他们并不善良。
Negress was one of the few words she took with her when she emigrated from Barbados to Manhattan. As a Negress, her passport to the world was restricted. The world has its limits. Shortly after arriving in New York in the late '40s, my mother saw what her everyday life would be. Being bright, a high school graduate, and practical, she'd looked at the world she had emigrated to, picked up her servants' cap, and began starching it with servitude.
“Negress”是她从巴巴多斯移民到曼哈顿时随身携带的少数几个词之一。作为一名黑人女性，她通往世界的通行证受到了限制。世界有它的局限性。40年代末抵达纽约不久后，母亲就看到了她每天的生活会是什么样子。她聪明、高中毕业、务实，看着她移民到的世界，拿起了她的佣人帽，开始用奴役精神给它上浆。
In her new country, my mother noticed that some New Yorkers retain the fantasy that in writing or speaking about the underclass or the oppressed silent woman or the indomitable stoic, they were writing about the kind of Negress she was. But they weren't.
在这个新国家，母亲注意到一些纽约人保留了一种幻想：在撰写或谈论下层社会或受压迫的沉默女性或不屈的坚忍女性时，他们写的就是她那样的黑人女性。但他们写得不对。
I think my mother took some pleasure in how harsh the word Negress seemed to the citizens in her adopted home. I think my mother took pleasure in manipulating the guilt and embarrassment white and black Americans alike felt when she called herself a Negress, since their view of the Negress was largely sentimental, maudlin, replete with suffering. When my mother laughed in the face of their deeply presumptive view of her, one of her front teeth flashed gold.
我想母亲对于“Negress”这个词在她的领养之家的市民听起来有多么刺耳感到一些乐趣。我想母亲对于操控白人和黑人美国人在她称自己为“Negress”时感受到的愧疚和尴尬感到乐趣，因为他们对黑人女性的看法在很大程度上是感伤的、多愁善感的、充满了苦难。当母亲面对他们对其极其自大的看法而大笑时，她的一颗门牙闪烁着金光。
For years before and after my mother's death, I refer to myself as a Negress. It was what I was conditioned to be. I have expressed my Negressity by living fully the prescribed life of an anti-man, what Barbadians call a faggot. Which is a form of kinship, really, given that my being an anti-man is based on greed for romantic love with men temperamentally not unlike the men my mother knew.
在我母亲去世前后的多年里，我称自己为“Negress”。这就是我被训练成的样子。我通过充分生活在一种反男性的处方生活中表达了我的“Negressity”，巴巴多斯人称之为“faggot”（基佬）。这确实是一种亲属关系，考虑到我作为一个反男性是基于对与我母亲所认识的男人在性格上并无二致的男人那种浪漫爱情的贪婪。
I socialized myself as an anti-man long before I committed my first act as one. I also wore my mother's and sisters' clothes when they were not home. Those clothes deflected from the pressure I felt in being different from them. As a child, this difference was too much for me to take. Those women "killed me," as comedians say, when they describe their power over an audience. I wanted them to kill me further by fully exploiting the attention I afforded them. But they couldn't, being women.
在我就第一个行动作出承诺之前很久，我就把自己社交为一名反男性。当她们不在家时，我也穿我母亲和姐妹的衣服。那些衣服缓解了我因与她们不同而感受到的压力。作为一个孩子，这种差异让我无法承受。正如喜剧演员形容他们对观众的权力时所说的，那些女人“杀了我”。我想要她们更彻底地杀了我，通过充分利用我给予她们的关注。但她们不能，因为她们是女性。
My mother killed herself systematically and not all at once. Perhaps that is because, as a Negress, she had learned stamina, a stamina that consisted of smiling and lying and maintaining the hope that everything would eventually be different, regardless of the facts. Until the end, my mother avoided the facts. She was polite. She imposed her will by not telling anyone what was really wrong. This kept everyone poised and at her service. She would not speak of the facts contributing to her death, nor would she speak of the facts that contributed to her wish to die in the first place. Not for the world would she have forfeited the will she applied to disappearing her own body, since it took her so many years to admit to her need for attention. And being ill was one way to get it.
母亲系统地、不是一次性地杀死了自己。也许这是因为，作为一名黑人女性，她学会了耐力，一种由微笑、说谎和保持希望组成的耐力，即无论事实如何，一切最终都会不同。直到最后，母亲都在回避事实。她很有礼貌。她通过不告诉任何人到底出了什么问题来施加她的意志。这让每个人都保持着戒备并为她服务。她不会谈论导致她死亡的事实，也不会谈论导致她首先产生死亡愿望的事实。她绝不会放弃她用来让自己的身体消失的意志，因为她花了这么多年才承认自己需要关注。而生病是得到关注的一种方式。
My mother first became ill at the end of her love affair with my father. As with most aspects of my parents' relationship, it is unclear whether or not my father dictated the course their relationship would take. The difference between my mother and the woman he became involved with after my mother was significant. She consented to live with my father, whereas my mother had not. After my mother refused to marry him, my father never asked her to again.
母亲是在她与我父亲的爱情故事结束后第一次生病的。和我父母关系的各个方面一样，我父亲是否决定了他们关系发展的方向尚不清楚。我母亲和我父亲在她之后与之发生关系的那个女人之间的差异是显著的。她同意与我父亲住在一起，而我母亲没有。在我母亲拒绝嫁给他之后，我父亲就再也没有求过她。
I know my mother encountered my father's girlfriend once on the street. My father's new girlfriend was in the company of one of my father's sisters. My mother saw a certain resemblance between my father's new girlfriend and herself. They were both homely but spirited, like Doris Day. It was clear to my mother that his new girlfriend was capable of withstanding my father's tantrums, his compulsive childishness, and his compulsive lying.
我知道母亲在街上遇到过我父亲的女朋友一次。我父亲的新女朋友和我父亲的一位姐妹在一起。母亲看到我父亲的新女朋友和她自己之间有某种相似之处。她们都很平凡但有活力，就像多丽丝·戴一样。母亲很清楚，他的新女朋友有能力承受我父亲的暴脾气、强迫性的孩子气和强迫性的撒谎。
I think the resemblance my mother saw between herself and my father's new girlfriend shattered any claim to originality my mother had. And being a woman, she chose to be critical of the similarity rather than judge my father. Shortly afterward, she was made sick by a mysterious respiratory illness. In the end, I think my mother's long and public illness was the only thing she ever felt she experienced as an accomplishment separate from other people. And it was.
我想母亲在她和我父亲的新女朋友之间看到的相似之处，粉碎了她对自己原创性的任何主张。作为一个女人，她选择批评这种相似性，而不是评判我父亲。不久之后，她因为一种神秘的呼吸道疾病而病倒。最终，我认为母亲长期且公开的疾病是她唯一一次感到自己作为一个独立于他人的个体所取得的成就。事实也确实如此。
She was in love with my father until the end. They spoke every day on the telephone. They amused and angered one another. She called him Sip, which was short for Siprian, his given name. When he said her name, Marie, he said it in a thick Bajan accent, so that the 'A' was very flat. In his mouth, her name sounded like this-- "Ma-rie."
她直到最后都爱着我父亲。他们每天通电话。他们逗弄并激怒彼此。她叫他“Sip”，这是他的名字“Siprian”的缩写。当他说出她的名字“Marie”时，他用浓重的巴詹口音说，所以“A”的发音非常平。在他的嘴里，她的名字听起来是这样的——“Ma-rie”。
For years, I wanted to be part of a narrative as compelling to me as my mother's was, a narrative in which I too would be involved with a bad man resulting in heartache that would eventually lead to depression and endless suicide and the attention that can be garnered from all that. I was dwarfed by my mother's spectacular sense of narrative and disaster. She could have been a great writer.
多年来，我想成为一个像我母亲那样引人注目的叙事的一部分，一个我也将与一个坏男人纠缠不清、导致心碎、最终走向抑郁和无尽自杀以及能从所有这一切中获得的关注的叙事。我被母亲壮观的叙事和灾难感所淹没。她本可以成为一名伟大的作家。
I've never been comforted by the idea that writing her narrative down in fragments is at all equal to the power of her live-while-trying-not-to experience. She is so interesting to me as a kind of living literature. I still envy her allure. And I still envy her ability to love, no matter how terrible, no matter how coarse, and to allow that love to consume her, or literally parts of herself.
我从未因为将她的叙事片段写下来而感到安慰，这完全等同于她那活生生去经历的力量。作为一种活生生的文学，她对我来说太有趣了。我仍然羡慕她的魅力。我也仍然羡慕她去爱的能力——无论多么糟糕、多么粗俗——并让那种爱消耗她，或者从字面上消耗她身体的一部分。
I stand back from the model of her courage, just as I stand back from my desire to be taken in by love, even as I fear its power. I avoid all of this even though I have considered myself a Negress in the tradition of my mother. Time has not changed my point of view, nor has the knowledge that what divide people are not the dreary, marginal issues of race or class or gender, but this-- those who believe friendship and love dispel our basic aloneness and those who do not. This was the difference that divided me from my mother. Maybe all I can say in support of my difference from her is that she never missed herself while I was around.
我站在她勇气模式的背后，正如我站在我想要被爱所俘虏的欲望的背后，即使我害怕它的力量。我回避所有这一切，尽管我一直认为自己是追随我母亲传统的“Negress”。时间并没有改变我的观点，知识也没有——那些分裂人们的不是种族、阶级或性别这些沉闷的边缘问题，而是这一点：那些相信友谊和爱能驱散我们基本孤独感的人，和那些不相信的人。这就是我与母亲之间的分歧。也许我能用来支持我与她不同的唯一一点是，当我在场时，她从未错过自己。
An excerpt from Hilton Als' book, The Women.
希尔顿·艾尔斯的书《女人》的节选。
Act Five. What can we really understand about our parents' romances? Well, all this hour, we've heard from grown children talking about their parents. Now, we hear from a parent. Reporter Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City and one of his children.
第五幕。我们能真正理解父母的浪漫史吗？好吧，这整个小时，我们都听到了成年子女谈论他们的父母。现在，我们来听听一位父母的心声。记者斯科特·卡里尔在盐湖城和他的一名孩子交谈。
Do you know how Mom and I met?
你知道妈妈和我怎么认识的吗？
I think you were working on an antelope story and Mom was doing filming, or something. You met each other and then you liked each other and then you married each other.
我想你当时正在写一个关于羚羊的故事，妈妈在拍摄，或者是之类的。你们认识了，然后你们喜欢上了对方，然后你们结婚了。
I remember sitting on my front steps in the morning, waiting for her to ride up the hill on her bicycle. It was in the spring, late April, and it had been raining, steam coming up off the street and sidewalks. I was waiting on the steps, and I realized that I was in love with her and that everything was going to be different now. She'd ride up the hill and set her bike down on the grass, and we'd go inside and she'd live with me there for a long time, maybe forever. I knew it. I saw the whole thing coming, just like I see everything now. The only thing missing is the ending.
我记得早上坐在前门台阶上，等她骑自行车上坡。那是春天，四月下旬，下过雨，街道和人行道上冒着蒸汽。我等在台阶上，意识到我爱上了她，一切从此将变得不同。她会骑车上坡，把自行车放在草地上，我们会进去，她会在那里和我住很长一段时间，也许永远。我知道。我看到了这一切的到来，就像我现在看到一切一样。唯一缺少的是结局。
I remember lots of times you were nice to Mom. I mean, she told me once that for her birthday or for Christmas or something, you bought her perfume and you wanted to get her the right one. And so you went around and you had a sample of each, and you were smelling it. And you couldn't decide which one to give her. And then when you come home, you hug her.
我记得很多次你对妈妈很好。我是说，她有一次告诉我，为了她的生日或是圣诞节什么的，你买了香水，你想买对那一款。所以你到处去，每种都试了样，你在闻。你无法决定买哪一种。然后当你回家时，你会抱她。
My house inside had no furniture other than two chairs and a table. I made some coffee and moved the table over by the window so she could sit in the sun. She was a modern dancer, small and thin, wearing a white, cotton blouse, no bra-- no need for a bra-- shorts and sandals, and sweating a bit from the ride. Her skin was dark tanned, already so early, lovely legs, but with lots of scars on the knees and shins, and feet that were like little creatures unto themselves, beautiful and frightening. They had the structure of the Golden Gate Bridge, a high, sinewy arch with built-in springs and pulleys and long toes, stretching out for perches.
我的房子里除了两把椅子和一张桌子，没有其他家具。我冲了点咖啡，把桌子移到窗边，这样她可以坐在阳光下。她是一位现代舞者，娇小瘦弱，穿着一件白色棉质衬衫，没有戴胸罩——不需要戴胸罩——短裤和凉鞋，因为骑车出了一点汗。她的皮肤晒成了深褐色，那么早已经这样了，可爱的腿，但膝盖和胫骨上有许多伤痕，脚就像小生物一样，美丽又令人恐惧。它们有着金门大桥的结构，高耸、强健的足弓，内置弹簧和滑轮，长长的脚趾，延伸出来寻找栖木。
Do you feel like anything's a mystery between Hillary and me that you don't understand?
你觉得希拉里和我之间有什么你无法理解的谜团吗？
[SILENCE]
[沉默]
This week, when I ask our 11-year-old daughter Jesse this question, she pauses for at least a half a minute. I've asked maybe a million questions in my reporting career, but this has got to be the longest pause I've ever heard.
这周，当我问我们11岁的女儿杰西这个问题时，她沉默了至少半分钟。在我的报道生涯中，我可能问过一百万个问题，但这一定是我听过最长的一次沉默。
I don't really think about it much. And it's a hard thing to think about.
我不太思考这个问题。而且这是一件很难思考的事情。
Why?
为什么？
Because I usually don't pay much attention to what you and Mom are doing between each other. But kind of, I do. And I don't really wonder anything. I don't think that there's something that I don't know that I really want to know, like a mystery or anything.
因为我通常不太注意你和妈妈在彼此之间做什么。但某种程度上，我注意到了。我不真的感到奇怪。我不认为有什么我不知道的、我真的非常想知道的东西，比如谜团之类的。
I'd seen her dance the night before in front of a small audience downtown, and her style was wrapped around the idea, her idea, that she really weighed nothing at all and that her body was only there to tell little jokes, her little jokes, whatever might come to mind. I asked her if she liked my house, and she said she liked the view. She asked me what I thought about her concert, and I said, "I thought it was funny."
前一天晚上我在市中心的一个小观众面前看过她跳舞，她的风格围绕着一个想法，她的想法，即她真的什么重量都没有，她的身体只是为了讲些小笑话，她的小笑话，无论想到什么。我问她是否喜欢我的房子，她说她喜欢这里的风景。她问我对她的音乐会怎么看，我说：“我觉得很有趣。”
She said, "Funny? Only funny?"
她说：“有趣？只是有趣？”
"Funny and beautiful," I said.
“有趣而美丽，”我说。
And she said, "That's better."
她说：“那还不错。”
Do you think Hillary and I are in love?
你觉得希拉里和我相爱吗？
Yeah. I mean, because you sometimes have fights. I think people who love each other have to have fights sometimes, otherwise they don't understand each other very well. Not everybody is exactly the same. And so people might disagree about something, but two people who love each other have to understand each other. And to understand each other, they have to know what they're thinking.
是的。我是说，因为你们有时会吵架。我认为相爱的人有时必须吵架，否则他们不能很好地理解彼此。并不是每个人都完全相同。所以人们可能会对某事有分歧，但相爱的两个人必须理解彼此。为了理解彼此，他们必须知道对方在想什么。
Up until this time, I had been living alone and was not unhappy. I had a house and a dog and a car. No job. No need for a job. I had money from the National Endowment for the Arts to produce a radio story about chasing antelope, which, as far as I could tell, only required a wholehearted effort to live as much like a primitive hunter as possible. It was a problem I was working on by myself. And really, I had no idea how to go about it, other than by trying to live simply and by trying to stay outside and cover as much ground as possible. But there she was, finally arrived, come to stay.
在那之前，我一直独自生活，并不觉得不幸。我有一所房子，一条狗，一辆车。没有工作。不需要工作。我从国家艺术基金会得到了一笔钱，制作关于追逐羚羊的电台故事，据我所知，这只需要尽全力像原始猎人一样生活。这是一个我独自一人正在解决的问题。而且真的，我不知道除了试图简单生活、留在户外并尽可能覆盖更多土地外，还能怎么做。但她在那儿，终于到了，决定留下来。
When you get married-- you ever thought about getting married?
当你结婚时——你有没有想过结婚？
Not really. Not much.
没有。不太想。
You haven't thought about it at all? You've never thought, well, when I get married, it'll be like this?
你一点儿都没想过吗？你从来没想过，嗯，当我结婚时，它会是这样的？
No. I never thought, like, "When I get married I will have," or, "It will be exactly like this," or something like that.
不。我从来没想过，比如，“当我结婚时我会有什么”，或者，“它会完全像这样”，或者诸如此类的话。
Maybe a little bit.
也许有一点点。
I don't know. I mean, I don't believe we can never guess the future. I can hope, but I don't like saying what I want to be when I grow up because you never know.
我不知道。我是说，我不相信我们能预测未来。我可以希望，但我不喜欢说我长大后想成为什么，因为你永远不知道。
She asked me why I only had one fork in the kitchen. I said it was all I needed and then asked her how many she had in her kitchen. "Eight," she said, "and at least 10 spoons. And I have some glasses, different kinds. Even wine glasses. I like to have friends over. I like to cook and have friends over to eat. Don't you have any friends?"
她问我为什么厨房里只有一把叉子。我说这是我所需要的全部，然后问她厨房里有多少把。她说：“八把，至少10把勺子。我还有一些玻璃杯，不同种类的。甚至还有酒杯。我喜欢请朋友来。我喜欢做饭，请朋友来吃。你没有朋友吗？”
"Yeah, I have a friend. But he doesn't have any hands," I said, looking over at my dog.
“是的，我有一个朋友。但他没有手，”我说，看向我的狗。
"You know," she said, "I've been dreaming about you. I think I'm in love with you."
“你知道吗，”她说，“我一直梦到你。我想我爱上你了。”
How do you know she supports me?
你怎么知道她支持我？
She doesn't wish-- I mean, she doesn't say to us that she regrets that she married you, and maybe not having a job sometimes. And so she still appreciates what she has.
她不希望——我是说，她没有对我们说她后悔嫁给你，也许有时没有工作。所以她依然珍惜她拥有的东西。
I went downstairs and brought up the pieces of a wooden bed frame that had been left there by a previous tenant. I had the mattress and everything, and I asked where she'd like to have it. She said, "I like to sit in bed in the morning and drink coffee." So I moved the table and put the bed there in the sunlight.
我下楼把一张之前租客留下的木制床架搬了上来。我有床垫和所有东西，我问她想放在哪里。她说：“我喜欢早上坐在床上喝咖啡。”所以我移开了桌子，把床放在了那里的阳光下。
When you get married, if your marriage turns out like our marriage-- you know, between your mom and me-- would that be good enough for you, or would you want more than that?
当你结婚时，如果你的婚姻像我们的婚姻一样——你知道，在你妈妈和我之间——那对你来说足够好吗，还是你想要比那更多的？
I think it would be fine. I mean, you guys seem pretty happy. And I think that if my marriage-- if I got married-- was like yours, I would be pretty happy too. And I think I would try to make a little more money. But otherwise, getting along like that, I think that would be-- it would be a very-- it would be a good marriage.
我觉得会很好。我是说，你们看起来很快乐。而且我认为如果我的婚姻——如果我结婚了——像你们的一样，我也会很快乐。我想我会试着多赚点钱。但除此之外，那样相处，我觉得那会是——那会是一场很好的婚姻。
Scott Carrier and his daughter Jesse in Salt Lake City. He's been married for 11 years.
斯科特·卡里尔和他的女儿杰西在盐湖城。他已经结婚11年了。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Peter Clowney and Alix Spiegel. Contributing editors, Sarah Vowell, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，彼得·克劳尼和阿历克斯·斯皮格尔协助。特约编辑，萨拉·沃威尔、保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
The excerpt from "In Dreams Begin Responsibilities" is copyright 1961 by Delmore Schwartz, used by permission of the New Directions Publishing Company. If you'd like a tape of our program, you can call us at WBEZ in Chicago, the phone number 312-832-3380.
《在梦中开始责任》的节选版权归戴尔摩·舒瓦茨1961年所有，经新方向出版社许可使用。如果你想要我们节目的录音带，你可以拨打芝加哥WBEZ的电话，电话号码是312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。